كنت أفكر أنه سيتعين علينا
إلغاء شهر العسل أو تغييره،
وسيكون هذا خطئي كله. لقد تبادل المتزوجان حديثًا
لورين وجو فلووك من آن أربور
الأفكار في حفل صغير
يتطلعان إلى مدى الحياة مما
قادته أخت بليس جو.
الزوجان المتحمسان إلى المطار في رحلة من
ديترويت إلى سان خوان بورتوريكو حيث
كان من المقرر أن يبحرا في رحلة بحرية في منطقة البحر الكاريبي،
ولكن قبل أن ينطلقا حتى،
صدمت لورين زوجتي
ونظرت إليّ وقالت:
يا فارغًا، ليس لدي  جواز سفري، ماذا
نفعل، الكثير من الدمار بالتأكيد
على Instagram، بدأ جو في تسجيل
الأحداث الدرامية التي حاولوا معرفة كيفية
الحصول على جواز سفر عروسه إلى بورتوريكو بين
عشية وضحاها، أود أن أقول حوالي نصف
الرحلة أدركنا أن هذا
لا شيء  يمكننا أن نتوصل إلى فكرة
أننا سنذهب إلى العمل، وقد
ألقيت التحية على ماري، وكانت
تلك اللقطة البعيدة تتضمن شخصًا
غريبًا تمامًا، أحد المضيفات
يُدعى داستي ديلز، وهو جالس
القرفصاء بجوار الزوجين ومن المؤكد أن
داستي جاء  أخبرنا داستي بخطة،
أنت تعرف أن هذا هو ما يمكنني فعله يا جو،
سأعود إلى ديترويت مباشرة
بعد هذه المعركة وسأعود لذا
إذا كان بإمكانك بطريقة ما الحصول على جواز السفر إلى
DTW
حوالي الساعة التاسعة أو في أي وقت  لقد
وصلت، يمكنني بعد ذلك أن آخذه معي في
اليوم التالي إلى أتلانتا، اتصل جو بأخته
جاك وأسرعت
بجواز السفر المنسي إلى المطار، وهنا تقوم
بتسليمه إلى داستي
وبمساعدته وعدد قليل من موظفي دلتا الآخرين
على طول الطريق.  الطريقة التي وصل بها جواز سفر لورين
إلى سان خوان في الوقت المناسب، أعتبر أن
أعظم هدية زفاف يمكن أن
نطلبها كانت أكبر بكثير مني
خلال هذه العملية برمتها، لقد
علمتني الكثير عن أهمية
العمل الجماعي وقمنا بذلك  استغرقت الرحلة البحرية
حوالي ساعة ونصف لتجنيب
لورين وجو وقتًا رائعًا في
رحلة شهر العسل ولا أستطيع الانتظار
لرؤية اثنين من الضيوف المميزين الذين تمت
دعوتهم إلى حفل الاستقبال الخاص بهم في غضون
أسابيع قليلة داستي وموظف آخر في دلتا
الذي كان له دور فعال في تحقيق كل ذلك،
شعرت بأنني على الأرجح العروس الأكثر حظًا
على وجه الأرض بعد أن قام داستي بكل ذلك من
أجلنا، وهو ما غرس الإيمان في
داخلي بأنه لا يزال هناك أشخاص طيبون،
ولديك الكثير من الأصدقاء
والعائلة الذين يتابعونك.
قصتنا ونحن متحمسون جدًا للقاء داستي،
لذا لإحضاره هو
وزملائه من المضيفات إلى مجتمعها،
أنا متحمس جدًا وآمل أن نبقى أصدقاء
لفترة أطول بعد ذلك